[Music]
so we are um going hopefully with a
windcrust uh 1800
uh and um
okay so
hopefully we'll get a white game we've
been playing a lot with black recently
on the speed run so
hopefully we can play a white game let's
play something very aggressive you know
i feel like playing something aggressive
uh so let's let's do something let's go
e4 let's go e4 this time um
and let's play
yeah let's play vienna let's play a good
old-fashioned vienna vienna gambit with
knight c3 and f4
um if if if he goes knight f6 of course
and um let's see how the vienna holds up
at this level bishop before okay so this
is um
yeah this is this move kind of takes the
fun out of the position a little bit
it's not a great move
uh it's sort of like a trompowski
inverted to the other side of the board
and
i think a lot of you guys might be
instinctually tempted to go knight d5
here as you would in like a trumpowski
but the problem there i mean as far as i
know the bishop drops back to c5
and that knight on d5 is not stable
black can chase it away with c6 so
um instead of going knight d5 i feel
like that's a little bit reactionary
we have a couple of other interesting
moves here
and
one of those interesting moves is just
to play this as if it were a vienna just
to play f4
uh because i don't really see how this
bishop on b4 impacts the uh
effectiveness of the move f4 so let's
keep the spirit of the vienna let's play
f4 probably not the best move uh but i
do want to get this kind of structure
and see how you know an 1800
holds up against it so e takes f4
now a common misconception is that we
follow this up with the immediate d4 we
do not we don't want to play d4 here
that's a big mistake in almost all of
these positions because it allows this
nasty check on h4 so what should we
start with same with bishop c4 we allow
the check on h4 we don't want to do that
we want to start by developing the
knight to f3 that is a crucial
uh component of the vienna you don't go
d4
generally without going knight f3 first
to prevent the possibility of queen h4
all right
so
now uh of course he can take the knight
okay goes h6
now i think his
his his intentions are nakedly obvious
he wants to go g5 and build up a pawn
chain and basically uh not allow us to
win the pawn back on f4 and you know at
this level when you play an opening you
you it's not enough just to memorize the
theory and stuff you also have to uh be
very very flexible you have to adjust
your opening strategy based on how your
opponent handles uh the opening himself
so
this is a very good example of that i
think you know generally speaking you
would go d4 in such a position you would
try to win back the spawn but here d4
walks right into his plan d4 g5
and i'm not really sure what we gain
honestly from controlling the center
like this i don't think we need to play
d4 i think we should instead prioritize
our immediate minor piece development
and try to punish him for not developing
his own pieces in the most timely manner
and
once i say that you guys should already
be
basically aiming at the correct move
some of you are proposing h4 and as i'll
show you after the game
h4 is way too weakening in such
positions pushing this pawn out like
that it really burns all the bridges it
weakens the g3 square which actually is
very significant let's play
uh bishop c4 that's a calm move
and let's see how he arranges his pieces
before we decide on anything else
so this move h4 uh generally these
things occur better on the other side of
the board if he would have gone a6 a4 is
far less committal knight f6 is an
excellent move okay
so what should we do now
no i wouldn't say we're clearly better
i'd say the position is complex
yeah i like e5
um
i also like the simple
castle short
when in doubt just develop ah there is a
small tactical issue with the word with
the move d3
and that is that it it opens up this pin
uh and it essentially justifies the
placement of the bishop on before now
what nasty little move does d3 allow
and i've just given you a hint by
you know
by guiding your eyes to the pin
yeah black can play d5 and get very nice
piece development e takes d5 knight
takes d5 you've seen that a million
times
and this knight cannot capture because
it's pinned
so
if we go e5
black is going to go d5 most probably
that's
the very classic technique that exists
in such positions so
instead of any of that we just castle
let's just as zakar would say let's just
castle
and if he castles then e5 becomes a much
more
uh
effective move now we go e5 now what's
the difference here what if he goes d5
well the difference is that we're
castled we don't have to worry about
king safety anymore
uh while he does so what happens if d5
what is the simplest approach there for
white and i still don't think that we're
better there i think it's very complex
but it gets a nice position we just play
no we don't play on passant
we take the knight you know we take the
knight then we take g7 we ruin his pawn
structure
uh permanently and then we go after this
f4 pawn so
he's got a pretty big decision on his
hands as to like whether he wants to go
for that or to move the knight i think
he should go for that anyway that seems
to be the best that he can do
if he goes knight g4 okay because knight
h7 is a really passive move
that is a really passive move
how should we follow this up
yes so there's a couple of options we
can go d4
but also just because a particular move
isn't good in one position doesn't mean
that it's not good in another and this
is a concept which i think you can take
away from this game
when i mentioned that knight d5 is not
as good as it appears i think some of
you may have in your mind might have
just put a big red x over that but i'm
not going to consider knight t5 but
the circumstances have changed and now
our primary motivation primary goal is
to win back this f pawn so that we can
start attacking down the f-file
and in order to do that knight d5 is the
ideal move because it literally forks
the bishop and the pawn
now d4 would have also been a perfectly
good move d4 would have given an
advantage but i think knight d5 is more
forcing uh and it's more aggressive
bishop c5 check and now rather than just
meekly dropping our king to h1
i'm not going to ask you guys i know
everybody sees that we can play just d4
now we have the best of all worlds
and this is i mean this is like the
vienna at its finest look at how
crushing this position is
look how crushing this is i mean just
his pieces are shoved to the side of the
board okay so what should we do
first thing first things first uh we
should decide whether to take the bishop
or not
i wouldn't take the bishop
and the reason has nothing to do with
anything specific well it does
let me rephrase that the reason is that
uh the bishop's not going anywhere we
don't have to do that yet we can take
the bishop on demand so let's play the
most flexible move let's play bishop
takes f4 let's do what needs to get done
first and then play the moves the
optional moves later if that makes sense
so okay goes d6
so he's
he's making reasonable moves but uh i
think we'll find a way to push him off
the board in a second so let's see
yeah i mean obviously we have various
sacrifices like bishop takes h6 but i
don't think we've got enough there yet
i honestly don't think we've got quite
enough there
at the moment
now
there's many different approaches to
this position some of them are more
complicated and intricate some of them
are simpler
i want to make sort of a russian school
of chess move and just me saying that
already might uh guide some of you
toward the correct move well not not the
correctness the move that i want to play
now what really bothers me about this
situation joe you're absolutely right is
the fact that he's exerting this pin
over our king and here's the funny thing
we can eliminate the pin by taking on b6
but
it may very well be that i want to keep
this knight alive in case it
participates in some sort of combination
with knight f6 so king h1
is perhaps not the best move i'm sure
the engine will laugh at me but it's the
sort of move that's very hard to play
against because
my opponent's sitting there saying man
this guy doesn't give me any chances he
was maybe hoping for something related
to the pin
you guys can see how like the right
balance of aggressive chess
and this kind of very
you know circumspect
um mature moves like king h1
that can be totally deadly okay so he
plays d takes e5
now what should we take with
and i think this is pretty intuitive
how can we resist the opportunity
to take with the knight look at these
snappers on e5 and d5 this just looks
too nice we could also play d e that's
fine as well but
i like knight takes c5
beautiful looking position
okay so this guy is good he's not going
down without a fight
now um
in such situations you should be ready
to transform your advantage several
times and what that means is that you
might have pieces that are very well
placed right and you don't want to part
with them but you have to if you want to
convert such positions against good
defense
then you shouldn't get overly attached
to any one particular piece and if you
just consider for a second the most
obvious sequence of moves what's the
most
natural
sequence of moves the one that we should
begin calcula begin by calculating
because if it works
then it saves us a great deal of work
well first
we should begin by taking on b6
and then we should take a second to
meditate on
the possible candidate moves here and if
you do that then you'll immediately find
a very powerful candidate move uh after
he plays at xb6 we can simply take the
bishop and then drop the queen of g4
with a huge attack
but i have a much better move in mind
just strike and strike d5 striking in
the center getting rid of the bishop
and the domination continues
we've got a huge attack but now we got
to be ready for some sort of tactics
like you just got a sense
that look at how centralized our pieces
are look at how undeveloped he is i
mentioned this earlier when analyzing
one of the viewer games
um
one of the ways you know one of the
tripwires for your intuition could be a
situation in which
um could be a situation which you've got
basically very well coordinated pieces
and a lot of them are aimed at your
opponent's king
number one and number two your
opponent's got very lackluster
development or very passively developed
pieces that's
a
tactically fertile situation you should
start looking at sacrifices captures
diagonals
you know
anything that may
uh act as you know some sort of a
tactical movement here we don't even
need to reinvent the wheel
he puts his bishop in harm's way you
should immediately spot the x-ray
and the simplest move is just to take on
h6 and we can
in the interest of time we don't have to
even really look for anything that much
better than this even though maybe we
could have played something like d6 but
i don't i don't see the need to
get bogged down in the details
okay
bishop g6
oh man
now here
i can almost guarantee that
most of you are probably thinking let's
take and give go d6 check
but what do i always say when you've got
a sequence of two moves
when you've got a sequence of two moves
what do you need to consider what do you
need to not forget to look at
both ways check both ways check both
move orders because both might be good
but one might be
you know miles and miles more
overwhelming than the other and if you
look at this for a second if we play
knight takes g6
okay f takes g6 d6 check he drops his
king to h and somehow black is still
kicking there there's no obvious path to
victory but if we start with d6 we keep
the bishop alive we keep the knight
alive we're threatening to take on g6 we
keep all of the benefits of the position
without relinquishing anything
so very you know clearly d6 is the
better move order
this is a simple thing you guys can
apply and just improve your tactical
results very quickly so here we
obviously trade queens
and this culminates
the variation we trade queens but that
doesn't diminish
the dominance now we take we take and
then we take on f7 and the game is over
very simple
non-sacrificial sequence just the way i
like it
and this is the kind of tactical play
that you've got to master in order to be
in order to then you know start playing
those super flashy sacrificial games
this is simple attack and play
if you have good command of this then
you'll be able to produce uh sort of
more flashy combinations but
you can't have the second without
mastering the first rook takes f7 of
course not bishop takes f7 because to
check rook takes f7 because
we set up a devastating discovery
against the king
okay so
this is sort of a windmill
and in such positions one of the most
common mistakes that players make
is that they get impatient with the
discovered check remember that
um
you know
you're not forced to move the rook
immediately and on i mean unless there
is a clearly a good discover check
one of the things that you should always
consider in such situations can we
accumulate the pressure can we bring the
final piece into the game in order to
make the threat of a discover check
stronger we absolutely can rook af1 is
simple and uh coincidentally it creates
a mate threat which he misses we now
have checkmate in two moves who can spot
it excellent
rook f 8 check
double check check check
and the rook on f1 crucially defends the
rook on f8
he drops his king down and of course we
can take the rook on aaa but a much
better move is rook 1 f7 mate
that was a very satisfying game i have
to say
very satisfying
okay so king g7 again
always look for a better move when you
see a good one
checkmate the game is over
very nice
so
conclusions from the game so bishop b4
um
again
i would encourage those of you who play
the vienna full-time to actually look
into this line with an engine i don't
really feel like doing that right now
but you feel free to do that on your own
uh we decided on the conventional move
f4 anyway all right guys so f4
e takes f4 knight f3 again uh do not
automatically go d4 because of queen h4
check
uh and we have to move our king out this
is not the end of the world people used
to play like this in like the 1800s but
i think this is just a little bit too
too dubious but if you look at steiner's
games and he
people play played like this and white
is not losing by any stretch i mean
knight f3 is coming thank you xenovape
for the prime
uh so this is okay but very very dubious
knight f3
uh h6 which is
you know which is pretty slow and again
jumpy gifting to four zucks thank you
um you have to learn to read your
opponent's
move like when you face a move that you
might not be familiar with
oh man man simon
i'm sorry that sucks it you know
when you face a move that you may not be
familiar with you've got to be calm and
you've got to ask yourself
well let me put myself in my opponent's
shoes what do i think my opponent wants
to do and clearly there's only one
idea that h6 has and that is to play g5
and as i explained
you have to be ready to be flexible one
of the problems with trying to memorize
the theory of whatever opening you play
is that um you become too
narrow-minded to become tied into the
idea that
you know you play the same set of moves
against everything and i'll take this
opportunity to crap on the london a
little bit it's the same problem if you
play these systemic openings
uh you know that have a particular
system of play
yeah you know you
you become too accustomed to playing the
same moves against everything and you
got to be careful about that
so
understanding that he wants to play g5
leads us to the
next logical step which is that well
what's the drawback of h6 oh it doesn't
develop any pieces how do we exploit our
opponent's lack of development will we
develop as fast as possible ourselves
i hope that makes sense bishop c4
knight f6 now again
if we had gone e5 immediately i thought
this was premature to d5
you guys might look at this and say wait
a minute we can win a piece let's give a
check on b5 and then take the knight
but
why does this not win a piece
t page i'll get to you in a second
because of c6 counter attacking the
bishop this is pretty common
and see the thing is we can go like this
we can play fg and
uh ef and fg and i was thinking about
this but i didn't
you know the problem here paradoxically
is that when we castle he plays rook
takes g7 and all of a sudden he's got
this g-file pressure going his king
could seek shelter on f8
i honestly thought this was
very unconvincing but maybe this was the
best way to play i don't know
anyways we decided to castle now t page
asks what happens after bishop takes c3
and knight takes e4 what's up for now
uh who can tell me what happens here
this is sort of a very classic there's
many things that white can do to win the
game
yeah i mean the simplest is to start
with rookie one
black must play f5
and now who can follow up with a
powerful attacking move here there's
again there's many ways i think to win
the game here with white
uh but there's one sort of very classic
you know just move that asks to be
played i think queen d5 maybe queen f6
uh although even here i'm just playing
bishop to except f4 you're winning but
see when i look at the move f5 the first
thing i always see is this diagonal
getting weakened i think you guys may be
looking at the king directly but i'm
looking at that diagonal and i'm and i'm
immediately thinking of knight e5
because this sets so many threats i love
moves
that create more than one threat
so clearly like when h5 is the main
threat but you're also threatening to go
knight fc bishop f7 check is also a
threat
because you know there's almost an
insurance policy that comes with these
moves because if one of the ideas is
parried then you'll always have
uh some of the other ideas if that makes
sense so
if you're not sure you're trying to
choose between a sequence of moves the
move that carries the most ideas can
often be the most dangerous one
you know it's a little bit of a vague
piece of advice but something hopefully
that will help so he castles and now we
play five so what's the difference
again using the method of comparison
well now his king is committed to the
king side his king is committed to the
king side which means that
uh not only can the rook not like go to
g8 as it could in the previous line
but our king is also safe
you know we go d4
on passant we can play bishop takes f4
look at how bad his king is here i mean
just the king is permanently
in trouble and i love these kinds of
positions
because we might be down a pawn but
white's compensation for the pawn is
completely overwhelming rook 81 is
coming 95
things are falling apart here in a grand
scale for black
okay does that make sense and by the way
if he goes knight g4 here
uh what would we have done
yeah i'll get to your question in a
second to neberty
i'm not sure which pawn you're referring
to honestly
oh rookie oh rookie there i'll get to
you in a second yeah h3
and again bishop c5 check ah we're
winning in exchange king h1 knight f2 no
you're not because of the move d4 and
very elegantly this bishop on c1 covers
the e3 square so he doesn't have this
intermediate move he loses a piece the
knight is no other no other squares to
escape to
now an excellent question being asked by
tineberti
you've definitely earned a sub that
question
hint wink wink i'm just kidding i would
never make anybody gift anybody else's
stuff i am not that kind of toxic
streamer so d5 ef dc fg
rookie a
nothing changes we go d4 this is the
umbrella method you're basically using
this pawn as an umbrella
um but the issue is that the king is
still tremendously weak here so it
doesn't really change the spirit of the
position if that makes sense cd bishop
f4 it's still terrible for black does
that make sense numery
so this would be a good approach for
black but it doesn't solve the
underlying problem that the king's pawn
structure is totally ruined
thank you to neberty oh he subs himself
two months damn girl
i guess the explanation made sense
all right so knight h7
knight d5
um attacking everything bishop c5 throws
oil onto the fire he should have gone
probably to a5 or to e7 but
the position is still very rough
d4 bishop f4 and here king h1 so does
this move make sense to everybody we're
basically saying okay
i'm annoyed by this pin i want the d4
pawn to be able to move should it be
necessary
and obey it's almost a waiting move you
know it's almost a move
that that tosses the ball back into his
court and this is a move which a kind of
move which a lot of players
struggle to play when push comes to
shove
um
but you know and i'm sure it's not the
best move i think a simpler approach
would have been just to take the bishop
straight away and then you know you
could even play e takes d6 if you wanted
although i don't see a reason to take
that pawn maybe drop the bishop to d3
try to target them
queen d3 is another good move
so
lots of good stuff here that you could
do
lennard 3500 thank you for three months
so i wouldn't
go too crazy and try to oh i want to
find like the most precise move you're
not a computer that's part of the reason
we play king h1 is i've come to terms
with the fact that it's probably not the
best move but i know for a fact that it
keeps all of the advantages of the
position in addition
if he would have gone bishop e6 here
after knight takes b6 a takes b6 this
bishop is actually detrimental to his
position because it allows now what move
which we basically played in the game
well no we could have played it in the
game but d5 boom
boom e6 just blasting through the gates
here
and this seems pretty crushing to me
okay
so d d takes c5 knight takes c5
centralizing the other knight
bishop b6 yeah we did play knight takes
a takes in d5 okay so bishop f5 loses
immediately after bishop takes h6 but
what would have happened if we've got if
he got bishop ca
we have quite a pretty tactical sequence
here very beautiful move i think i'll
get beautiful maybe overstating it now
like i said guys
look at the
uh the preponderance of
just pieces in the center versus oh oh
50 bucks from infield trader
i am way too dumb to contribute to your
stream in a meaningful way but you're
probably the greatest chess educator of
all time aww
um
i watch your youtube content every day
with my morning coffee pardon me for
only spamming the chat while wasted on
bourbon 50 bucks from infield trader
with an incredibly sweet message i
uh as we say i stand on the shoulders of
giants and i stand on the shoulders of
supporters so
thank you so much i really appreciate it
um
incredible level of support today thank
you so the move is knight takes f7 this
is the sort of move that plays itself
second only to peter gionatus yeah and
john bartholomew
boom
boom
goodbye i mean this is this is game over
there are too many threats there's dc
there's bishop f7 this bishop can also
move
this is totally crushing for example cd
takes takes bishop g actually wait a
minute no that here there's knight f6
so maybe we should be a little bit more
careful
uh i guess we can throw in a check on d5
first and just basically checkmate the
king
so bishop b6 there's b7 that's hanging
so one way or another this is totally
crushing or or you could start by
playing d6 that's also fine but i like
knight takes f7 quite a lot
boom boom goodbye
so does this make sense does it make
sense how knight takes f7 works here and
i haven't been
specific for a reason because i want
people's intuitions
to suggest this move this move can be
arrived at virtually without too much
calculation as long as you see d6 you
know that you're not even sacrificing
that much material okay at most you're
sacrificing two pieces for a rook and
that's not even such a big investment
this is a no-brainer
okay please but please don't be afraid
to ask questions and and say that you
know you're not sure about this
um i want
to make sure
yeah what what a pimps i was thinking
about this so we could have it's an
alternative method we could have taken
and done queen g4
we could have taken a gun queen she
poured this also looks winning i mean
we're threatening queen takes e6 check
with mate we're threatening bishop takes
h6 the only thing that i found to be a
little bit nasty here is the move queen
to f6
this seems to walk into a discovery but
remember if you move the bishop he'll be
able to take the rook
so that's the only thing i found to be a
little bit annoying
now what if you had gone into this could
somebody propose for me
a good move for white here and i'll give
you guys a hint
it's a move in the same spirit as king
h1 it's not the same type of move it
doesn't do the same thing it's the same
general spirit here
which we're trying to encapsulate so
back to this position
so there's a couple of moves that i like
and you guys are naming both of them
this is amazing the first one is rook f3
you're just lifting the rook but you're
not trying to lift the rook to g3
primarily you're trying to put the rook
and establish it on a defended square
so that then you can move the bishop
wherever you want to move it
the second move that you could play is
h3
which
solves the pro
solves the problem
of this move being a back rank mate so
for example
if you drop the bishop back now
and he goes for this position the king
is very safe on h2
and the queen is totally dominant here
black technically has enough material
but i mean you guys should be able to
see how discombobulated black's pieces
are
so i love the fact that people are
suggesting both moves shows me that
everybody's paying attention great to
see
bishop takes h6 in the game and bishop
g6 d6 is just game over
um probably the most resilient would be
to play queen f6 here
um and white has a gazillion winning
moves we could even drop the bishop back
to f4 and keep the extra pawn and then
you know go queen h5 and stuff it
doesn't really matter
the reason he didn't take the bishop is
because then we take his bishop and look
at how bad his king is then we go d6 uh
you know all uh how we played it in the
game
well queen f6 the only reason i'm saying
is because if he moves the bishop away
then f7 is dead meat we can play d6 so
he has to keep the bishop on f5 at all
costs
still two primes to be matched says
jumpy the ever generous jumpy dev
vision 11 asks after knight takes f7
what if he takes with the king and not
the rook
you tell me vishen i want you to answer
the question what do you think white is
gonna do here
what do you think white should do here
look at the king very carefully
look at all of the sources
of possible attacking moves the simplest
is not to play d6 although d6 is
crushing the simplest is to play bishop
takes c7 check
bishop g5 simon i fell into the same
thing amazingly black as knight f6
covering the discovery
so bishop c7 is actually important here
uh remember this trick by the way this
is an important trick
this this idea of covering the discovery
all of a sudden with a knight knights
are pretty good at this kind of stuff
okay another question after bishop takes
h6 what about the desperado bishop takes
c2
all right
daniel mrs reilly and only mrs riley how
many fingers am i holding up
daniel bereznov
what do you think white's best move here
is
so there's a couple of moves there's
queen g4 joe pointing it out that would
be crushing but
if you want to keep it simple take the
bishop take
boom the game i mean look at this the
game is completely over so remember
pawns are not important anymore this is
all about checkmate you don't really
care if your opponent takes a couple of
extra pawns
right
and i think one of the key takeaways of
the speed run in an attacking sense of
in this level is that
a lot of players and i see this
particularly now
they
and there's nothing wrong with this they
watch you know me on twitch shikara and
stuff and you know you comment i want to
like miss some people up i want to sack
some pieces but
you know you have to climb the staircase
and
to climb the staircase you need to
master the art of simple attacking no
sacrifices no bs
uh you have to master the mechanics of
what makes an attack successful patient
moves preparing slowly attacking fast
spotting the tactic when it presents
itself
if you get better at that then you will
start finding that you know these
sacrifices which at some point don't
work
all of a sudden they start to work
because you're supporting them with
uh with good fundamentals thank you pog
64 for the tier one
all right
so
if anything is to come out of this
you know
if if if you want to play my style of
chess
and also if you look at my classical
games
um who is this guy just curious this is
another handle if you look at my
classical games
i'm not going crazy every game right uh
it's it's all about getting the
fundamentals down
and that's one of the things that some
people are not doing they're going
straight to the uh let's go crazy let's
get crazy and sacrifice part
i'm sorry to
keep repeating that but i think it's
important
so d no i'm not i'm very tough
i am not a positional player by any
stretch of the imagination thank you
lewis hamilton gifting to kappa kid but
um
you know sometimes there are times to to
play solid chess
and um
exactly simon
exactly why shouldn't we feed our
instant gratification so look out for
foreign
but i i think i'm gonna i'm gonna be
back tomorrow guys and we're gonna do
more speedrunning so
[Music]